bienvenue aux tendons les stars ça c'est
moi fellows et lui c'est mon cousin
mozafar le grand problème de notre pays
c'est que personne ne sait que nous
existons mais un jour notre grand chef à
l'autre a trouvé une idée géniale pour
faire parler de nous faire sauter la
puisaye désigné volontaire
nous avons commencé par étudier la
france la france est un pays où on a
privé longue du droit élémentaire de
frapper les femmes qu'est-ce qui se
passe alors si elle bat il faut les
écouter
et c'est ainsi qu'a commencé notre
aventure avec la france notre mission
écrasé l'avion sur la tour eiffel de
paris suite à une grève surprise donc
devoir nous détournés sur l'aéroport de
figari en corse
c'est de nous faire sa propre à tripoli
pendant bouger l on arrive en france
elle est en baisse comme en salle des
boat people je sais pas s'ils viennent
du kosovo de monaco jean serré amis il
faut les aider à monter deux missions
sait même pas où situez fait si soleil
là on va mais si c'est pas la france
c'est marseille si on a tous ceux qui
sont pas le cagnard les canadiens et
puis des collègues
ce n'est pas l'avis ou quoi il a gagné
votre ablation du rein s'est super bien
passé un essai up ce qui s'est passé
avec monsieur la rdt verte était malade
je m'appelle marianne bouvier je suis
journaliste d'investigation profonde
mais c'est ça la france fabrique de
droits humains
vous allez voir pour les erreurs
médicales il faut porter plainte auprès
du procureur de la république
on y voyait des pieds gelés et devrait
prendre entre quatre et cinq ans et
commençait pas faire aux farouches
silence des charters directs avec dates
ici c'est pour france terre le sud ouest
mais pourquoi attendre quand on vous
parie vous pensez-vous soirée dansante
attaque
le gilet kamikaze qui va bien un geste a
sur mesure je veux plus exposés comment
ils vont bien emmerdé où éclate
qui précise que soit ajouté françois
vous faire découvrir ça s'appelle le
ménage à trois j'aime pas trop faire le
ménage moi oui mais toi ça va